Aaron Carter is giving back I'm just so
happy to be healthy happy here
supporting me go
[Music]
the singer looked better than ever as he
spent Thanksgiving volunteering at
Project Angel Food a nonprofit
organization that cooks and delivers
meals to those affected by
life-threatening illnesses the 29 year
old sang and shared a series of pics on
Instagram writing today I'm thankful to
be able to give back Happy Thanksgiving
to all my fans
Carter entered a health and wellness
facility in September where he stayed
for two weeks before checking out his
rep told et at the time he left due to
quote several legal and personal matters
the singer returned to the center in
mid-october and has since celebrated his
45 pound weight gain he tweeted that he
was quote feeling stronger and showed
off his progress on Instagram writing
that he felt quote amazing in July
Carter opened up to ET revealing he
suffers from body image issues I have a
hiatal hernia I have a stress condition
as an eating disorder how would you feel
every ever every two seconds seeing a
tweet view of aids go die oh look at
this meth head Oh meth kills
crack kills it's body shaming it is the
toughest thing to deal with